this is a show where we watch old worth
of episodes to see the
never-before-heard behind the scenes
juicy details of how the episodes were
made that was good the sentence was good
and when you add a juicy that really you
know cones in on this show cuz we eat a
lot of juicy things in honor of the last
episode whatever of 2019 we are watching
the Fried Chicken episode hello season
three doubling down on Fried Chicken a
double down a fried chicken double down
yeah this is all all faked cuz I was
obsessed with this idea that we should
have a scene that opens every episode a
fun scene that's how the show started
and there was an homage to the beginning
and so that's what this is but it just
doesn't play well it doesn't what does
that what do they call it when it
doesn't like age well does it land yeah
didn't age well age to like milk but
this episode did age well I would still
want to know what this guy has around
his neck they sit there it's like some
kind of scavenger hunt he's got like
historical artifacts he's like living
national treasure behind the scene okay
can he go back to that run can we go
fight her
I just noticed how like how have you run
this kid in the background of the shot
yeah there are so many parts of the
interview where he's just like staring
straight at camera yeah I had to cut
around coming around
Hey
[Laughter]
I'm so hot shout out to Josh who did
that yeah it's a food that takes a bath
when it gets cold it has to be good you
taste good up your back the stuff that
you get away with Sam by that it just
immediately moving on who know him or me
Andrew yeah I agree obviously a bad it
takes a bath when he gets up it has to
be good
no that's soup traumatic or dramatic you
just make a pun
yeah so I definitely did not intend to
do that fun and I actually did not know
what you're talking about when you say
it really was that have fun yeah I'm
like it this is the person you're
hearing this that's true yeah no you
said dramatic or drum I know the pun now
but I assume 110 do but what were you
saying plays a traumatic the traumatic
or dramatic dramatic or traumatic I I
didn't know that until this very moment
okay so this is something that we didn't
notice until a common term we need it
out to us after the video is uploaded
obviously that's how comments work
you're about to see a bird flying into a
parked car is tired really sad I mean I
mean hilarious and it's sad let's see
the footage
oh it doesn't hit the tire oh my god
what does it think of doing but the bird
is fine it just okay I think the
commenter said did a bird just hit that
car tire because it is kind of deceptive
you don't know whether it's just doing a
quick flip around or if it actually
bounces off the tire yeah either way it
looks like the bird is fine we would not
be making light of this if we thought
that the bird was hurt in any way this
is one of the first times that I was
truly starstruck by a person we were
interviewing Marcus Samuelsson had been
on Top Chef
you know many you know TV Food Network
that kind of thing yeah I agree I as you
can tell we didn't really know what I
mean we did we nail the interview but it
was still it's hard to portray exactly
how you felt nervous so this is one of
the best foods I've actually eaten on
this show yeah I think about this a lot
you know I get sad that it's not here
annoying so interesting how the recipe
for fried chicken is so simple uh-huh
but it's so different at every place you
go to I should say like it has the same
few essential components but then
there's so much variation that each
person can put on even the way they just
bread it and dredge it and then how many
times you fry it what temperature do you
fry it how long do you fry it for was
the seasoning like like the t-shirt of
foods sure Adam
so this moment mm-hmm had a lot of
comments on it from people who didn't
understand what was happening maybe the
most controversial moment warded history
in the comments I've ever seen yeah
explain what happened well okay so the
manga same wasn't comments by the table
eats the fried chicken with us and the
comments were like wow who is guy think
he is he's like coming and eating their
food from them
yada yada chill yeah there were a lot of
comments that were like wow he just ate
their chicken and then ran away but it
he made the chicken for us and it was
his yeah to try also the way that we
film this is that we'll usually do the
interview and then we film all the food
being made and then we're doing the
taste this at the end so we didn't
expect him to come back up to us at the
table he was just gonna say bye we were
like you want to try some chicken and he
was like yeah of course and then he like
took a bite made a comment about it and
it in the edit kind of looks like he's
like you like stealing away with a bite
I owe what I think okay hey can I jump
in please I really thought I was gonna
get to eat that but well that's okay I
got in Kornberg wow you actually look a
little upset yeah I was I think I was
trying to play it as a joke lot of
people thought that he was being rude
but that's not the case it was always a
real problem is that you cannot deliver
a joke
cuz it money faults I think so we've
just found the root of the problem
that's my favorite part of the episode
what's even goes what do you say there
and
basically we're serving in fried chicken
like peeking duck with caviar I
understand how stupid and almost douchey
it sounds by no means am i trying to
disrespect fried chicken
Horrocks have you are I think it works
for men I think yeah people always ask
for more David Chang on our show and I
think it's because he just emanates this
excitement for food yeah it really is
contagious and that's what I like about
for sure
very light-hearted but also very
knowledgeable and informative let's look
at the not a taxi yeah
I did not realize we put all the
detailed information - chickens fried
whole 113 grams of Pacific white
sturgeon caviar 113 grams of smoked
steelhead trout roe chive crepes white
barbecue sauce creme fraiche potato
chips julienne cucumbers I've got in
many in-person comments from people that
they actually went and bought this fried
chicken yeah I was in line at a pizza
place once in New York and this guy was
like I'm a banker from Norway and I've
been here for six months I'm about to go
home but to this week I'm gonna have the
fried chicken caviar with my friends has
one last hurrah try not to have my hands
in Norway my goodness David give me a
cut already this is a I believe this is
a dish that Adam wanted to feature on
the show yes right in season one yeah
the first time we just got the doesn't
do filming they didn't at the time we
were very yeah I remember being
extremely nervous about doing this shoot
and doing it well this was like I was
like oh crap we're big leagues but we're
also just idiots look we'll get this
next segment also the music
yeah shots of Josh for this next segment
check this out
[Music]
[Laughter]
what is silly edit
you know it's wondered what David
thought about this edit I know he saw it
I'm a hundred percent Journeys I just
asked him so like I said I was very
nervous for this shoot and then when
this was how the Edit came out I was
like wow this music does convey the
giddy joy that is this expensive meal
experience which is the opposite of the
serious classical music white tablecloth
type of serious eating yeah it's like
when in movies you have the typical
trope of the person that comes from the
wealthy family who meets the person who
comes from the peasant class and they
and they fall in love and they get
married and they have wonderful family
together that is the fried chicken and
the caviar it's like that not a normal
trope of every movie I remember being so
nervous and trying to talk about food in
front of mr. David there yeah I was just
like god I hate myself I'm cringing
through this whole experience but it
ended up being fine last time because he
had his own ace up his sleeve so you
didn't actually know what was coming
next no I said that right you wanted to
dip it so so David Chang being the the
Wiley coyote that he is he was like okay
you can come to my restaurant in film
but then secretly he organized this
giant tin of caviar that he was gonna
like surprises with and we actually did
not know this was gonna happen for the
shoot
I love a mixture of plates very pleasing
that's something I aspire to have in my
own home but I think it takes a long
time to maybe one really hard weekend of
antiquing and I can get it together
I need some more pregnant Oh oh yeah I
don't remember that no yeah we used to
regularly put really great lines of
dialogue that were just too long to put
in the regular taste tests in the
PostScript like that yeah yeah we really
used to roll for way too long in the
taste test we still do the new yeah
that's what's fun about it though
because we get to just enjoy our time
when we're eating the food
yeah and be silly yeah yeah that might
be one of the greatest worth episodes of
all time by the way that we just watched
I think so for worth it
REE watches worth it yeah so if your
taste buds are fired up watching that
Fried Chicken episode go back and now
watch our recently released fried
chicken sandwich episode released this
past Sunday and we will be coming in
with more episodes in the new year so I
say we do a worth it re watch this
audience selection mmm how about that
maybe out the whole season because you
can't let them take the reins there too
long but maybe a few episodes we will
get Adam on the couch maybe both of us
behind the camera I like that you know
how it leads you review that thing will
you if this video gets X likes we'll do
that sure yeah does it amount a million
views right
that's worth it for 2019 all righty
that's it bye
you
[Music]